et déjà avec le droit au logement
opposable jacques chirac a donné du
travail à son ministre de la cohésion
sociale jean louis borloo qui a reçu
hier soir des représentants
d'associations notamment les enfants de
don quichotte
aujourd'hui xavier emmanuelli président
du haut comité pour le logement des
personnes défavorisées va remettre lui
un rapport dans lequel il insiste sur la
nécessité de fixer un calendrier pour
que le droit opposable au logement
puisse entrer dans les faits le point
avec llorente route du canal
saint-martin au ministère de la cohésion
sociale
les enfants de don quichotte ont fait
une grande enjambée hier au terme d'une
rencontre de plus de quatre heures avec
jean louis borloo leur charte a été
adoptée elle réclamait l'ouverture en
continu des structures d'accueil pour
les sdf
l'augmentation du nombre de logements
sociaux et l'instauration d'un droit au
logement opposable
pari réussi je veux faire la révolution
jusqu'à la cua ce groupe traitement
maintenant je crois que on a des
techniciens là où qui sont avec nous et
qui sont assez forts et qui disent que
c'est plutôt pas mal j'ai l'impression
voilà maintenant on attend de voir
jeudi si c'est pas ou mal appliquées là
c'est pas des tendres convection canal
saint martin on va mettre des bungalows
chalon survivre en le mouvement était
resté très parisien depuis sa création
début décembre
désormais elle s'étend aux grandes
villes de france à toulouse douze tentes
ont ainsi été montée sous la pluie une
vingtaine de sans logis s'ils sont
immédiatement installés d'avoir des gens
qui nous aident c'est bien peu
c'est chaud son avocat à lyon également
les enfants de don quichotte ont fait
des émules tente dressée place bellecour
charte diffusé non sans polémique
elle vient de l'association notre dame
des sans abri l'un des principaux
centres d'hébergement des sdf
ils ont eu le mérite de faire bouger les
choses
mais comme le dit sébastien de nos
collaborateurs je pense que c'est pas
faire injure j'étais un petit peu fort
de dire ça c'est un petit peu dérogeant
de mettre en cause les compétences des
gens qui sont plus aux abeilles en
attendant c'est une première une
vingtaine de bien logés ont passé la
nuit avec des sans abri